yes sake and I will make another YouTube
video we're gonna do a face swap of
YouTube pets and faces you've sent me so
what the [ __ ] is this is that an it what
is it yeah what all right let's start
with an easy one KB Turner and Griffin
you're very famous youtubers but what if
the situation was different
what if Griffin was not the famous one
do you ever feel like a Toby Turner what
are you doing babe you look so good
Griffin is done how the [ __ ] are we
gonna do Toby though that's what
fangirls ask every day but if Toby
what's a fairy it looks like they've
Toby's swallowed his moustache and it's
trying to choke it up looks so good
something very very disturbing about the
ice boots what the [ __ ] is that
I don't know nightmares for life
perfection very mixed responses Oh God I
accidentally clicked set as desktop
background is gonna give me this picture
was bound to happen sooner or later
done he's so stunning wha this is my new
favorite hobby hands damn oh my god I am
so sorry this is the best photo of all
time
[Laughter]
next up we have this picture of Ian from
smash I don't know how the hell I would
pull this off but let's try it out all
right it looks like ian is wearing a
furry dick on his face that I'm sorry
yeah alright [ __ ] seen it all okay I
can do it
how the [ __ ] am I gonna do the doll
alright I'm gonna try I'm gonna [ __ ]
try I guess as he has the ears I have to
somehow give him the haircut at million
dollar bowl haircut I'm having way too
much fun this is not it would seem that
the more [ __ ] these turn out the better
they are of God okay it's probably the
greatest Face Swap of all [ __ ] time
before if yeah whatever I don't know his
face look like it has a penis on it
that's what I said
I knew it heaven sent us this picture
I'll stop it it's it's straight from
hell baby don't even all right we have
time for one more one more baby tell you
key-in Corgi I want the hair
[Laughter]
this looks great already that's a good
sign
people say adopt a dog I say let your
dog adopt your hair so kawaii oh my god
I don't know what the [ __ ] is wrong with
me
[Music]
it looks even better in perspective
[ __ ] same cell fun this why I don't
sleep
all right first I left another episode
there if you like this video go ahead
and even leave a like a bit about
[Music]